Recently I was talking to a friend
who said that she knew "the perfect guy"
for me.
Because all he dates are Asians.
Anna: What?
Friend: Yeah, he totes has yellow fever~!
She said it like it was a good thing,
which it's not!
Men with "yellow fever" look at you and
they only see schoolgirls or sexual geishas.
They hide samurai sword collections in
their closet,
and they learn how to speak an Asian
language and only talk to you
IN THAT FREAKING LANGUAGE!
Guy(Japanese): Good morning. Are you well?
Uh..English is my first language.
Guy(Japanese): Is that so?
I..I would really prefer if we spoke English.
Cause you know. This is America..
You're white..?
Guy(Japanese): Ah, but, Japanese is so
beautiful, isn't it?
Okay.
(Guy bows)
Anna: Stop it.
These men, the problem with them..
is that they don't give a fuck about who
you really are.
The idea of you is enough.
I don't understand why, why you would
romantisize an entire race as being
submissive or weak or docile or delicate
or fragile
or whatever the FUCK is the allure of
Asian women!
Oh, I'm sorry, but do
these GUNS look like they're very
"submissive" to you?
No? Okay.
Well how about these?
And yet the exact opposite happens to
Asian men.
They have such a terrible history of being
emasculated. Sorry bro.
Now look, there's nothing wrong with having
a type. Having a type, knowing what you like,
what you're attracted to,
THAT'S FINE!
But yellow fever..
is when the only prerequisite for me to
become your potiential partner is the
color of my skin?
That's cheap. That's offensive. You're
an asshole. Go away.
Pisses me off so much.
Men come up and they're like,
"All my ex-girlfriends are Asian."
Like what the fuck does that mean to me?
That doesn't mean shit to me!
That just means you're a racist asshole!
You might as well come up to me and be
like, "I'm a racist asshole."
Because then at least I'll be like, "Oh,
he's honest! That's cool!"
Oh my GOD! OKAY!
Stay awesome, Gotham! I'll see you next week!
It's been a crazy week..
Oh, just a quick update on the short films.
So sorry that I'm behind on my 12 of the
year, the breakup and the move and all
that stuff kinda like, made me fall behind.
But I've got two beauty pageant ones
coming out. One is a fantasy,
post-apocalyptic-y beauty pageant
that Megan wrote, it's about a
contestant who keeps having strange visions.
And then I have an intergalactic
beauty pageant, which I wrote,
coming out in collaboration with
Ron Howard's studio, New Form Digital.
Then I'm also working on a puppet one, and
a dance one, and I'm just working working
working working, keep calm, work hard,
work smart, and you can do what--
I had coffee clearly today. YEAH!
I've been talking for a long time.
Alright, for real! Bye! EUGH!
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara